congratulations I mean can I tell you
Brandon I've missed watching you on the
big screen it's good to see you back how
does it feel really good thank you glad
to be here so obviously you're um
getting the spotlight award tonight for
the whale seeing the kind of reaction
and responses film has been getting it I
mean you must be beside yourself
I'm so happy people are seeing it people
are responding in a way that's
meaningful it's touching a lot of people
it's good so how does it feel to be able
to kick off the whole year really with
the Palm Springs International Film
Festival well we're uh we're already
underway it's going to be an exciting
next couple of weeks a lot to come I
think it'll be an exciting next couple
months too I mean obviously a lot of
people are saying you're a huge Awards
and Oscars Contender is that something
you pay attention to does it make you
nervous or does it kind of fill you with
pride especially because of this
performance I think if I wasn't paying
attention or felt a little bit of
butterflies I wouldn't have a pulse it's
true exactly it's exciting
um you know what has been the or whose
reaction maybe has been the most
surprising to your or something maybe uh
old pal from back in the day that you
heard from that you're like wow okay
thank you for watching man oh there are
plenty of friends of mine from school
from college days uh friends and
colleagues who have I worked with in
years past
I just heard from the director of School
Ties Bob Mandel hey Bob that was really
great he's pulling for me yeah this is
exciting it must be nice for you to be
able to reflect on your career at this
moment too because this is would you
consider this a peak
I'm just getting started that's right
[Music]